un match électrique avec des
rebondissements les spectateurs du
gymnase nicholas leur souviendront
longtemps de cette rencontre entre
plaisir des clés plus tôt après une
première période équilibrée aucune des
deux équipes n'arrive à se détacher au
score les yvelinois arrive à recoller
juste avant la pause à la dernière
seconde sur ce tir 13 partout après 30
minutes les joueurs répondent présents
enfin du temps ils ont dû mettre de
l'envié de l'agressivité et de la
lucidité en attaque on finit pas 13 13 à
la mi temps c'est un vrai match de
handball c'est un plaisir de jouer ce
genre de match c'est plaisant ça met du
contact ça joue au ballon et des arrêts
de gardiens voilà c'est c'était un bon
match au retour des vestiaires plaisir
les clés accélère et creuse l'écart les
deux minutes s'accumulent du côté de
plus tôt avec un avantage de trois buts
on pense locaux à l'abri mais le match
bascule en milieu de seconde période les
joueurs des hauts-de-seine profitent des
pertes de balle reviennent au score et
passe devant plaisir les clés ne
reviendra pas 29 à 26 à la chaussée
grosse déception
parce que
plus tôt c'était un concurrent direct
pour le maintien ni pour la montée mais
voilà il ya neuf équipes qui se tiennent
en trois ou quatre points et six ont
gagné aujourd'hui on passe est mort
pendant quarante minutes ont fait
quasiment jeu égal voire supérieur et
voilà sur les vingt dernières minutes on
déjoue complètement on perd trop de
ballons au classement plaisir les clés
et 9e du championnat de nationale 3
prochaine rencontre ce samedi 11
décembre sur le terrain du 7e morlaix